- Okay Jessica, here we go.
You are a Latina woman who's
in support of the wall.
How do you exist?
- My story is like this:
My dad is a coyotaje.
So what a coyotaje is in
Spanish is a smuggler,
a human trafficker.
I'd wake up sometimes
and there'd be a room
packed full of people
I've never met.
- Whoa.
- And we lived in
a small apartment,
so it was like I had to share
space with complete strangers.
- How many people?
- Let's say 12?
It was kind of awkward but--
- That's the word I would
use to describe waking up
to a room full of 12 illegal
immigrants, is awkward.
- A little awkward.
- Yeah.
What do you think
of those people?
- I don't know these people,
I don't know who they
are, what they've done.
Now that I think
about it as an adult,
I'm like, "How the hell
did my parents do that?"
- Right, that directly seems
super unsafe and
weird and creepy.
- Yeah.
- And maybe even a little--
and I don't like to
extreme language, awkward.
But I'm sure those people,
from their perspective,
were sitting there going,
"I feel terrible for this
"little girl, I'm just
like so desperate,
"what else am I
supposed to do here?"
Do you see it like that,
or do you just say,
"It doesn't matter how
desperate you were."
- It doesn't really matter how
desperate you are, you know?
Because here's my
perspective on the wall.
The difference between
my father back in the
80s-90s to today is that
you have people like my dad
pushed out, and now it's
run by the cartels which
obviously is like a
whole other world.
- So is that your main problem
with illegal immigration
at this point, is that it's
become co-opted by
criminal enterprise?
- That's one of the reasons.
- What do you think
that Donald Trump's wall
will accomplish to
stop the cartels,
and to stop illegal immigration?
- It would actually
do a couple of things.
So, what it would do is one:
we got the problem
of human trafficking.
So we're not only getting
human trafficking from people
that just want to come here
and make a better life,
we're getting sex slavery,
child trafficking,
we're getting so many
different types of trafficking
that are not by their own will.
- So you're saying
that the cartels
that are worth
billions of dollars,
some of the most powerful
criminal enterprises
in the world,
- In the world.
- you don't think that
they can afford a ladder?
I mean just--
- I mean, depends
what kind of wall
we're gonna have right?
- I mean you can't--
- It's not just gonna be
a physical concrete wall,
I'm sure there's
gonna be some kind of
new technology like sensors,
- Oh some spells
like Jon Snow style.
- and lasers, which
you never know.
- Right.
- I mean we're gonna need
that 'cause the Mexican people
and the people from the
South are very resilient
and were very, ingenious,
"we'll figure it out."
- Yeah.
- So it can't be just
made out of concrete,
'cause we'll bust through it.
- Would you prefer if
we went back to small
mom and pop coyote operations?
- No, I'd prefer that we didn't
do any coyote operations.
- Let's say we have to.
- If we have to?
- Yeah.
Put your dad back in business?
- Well, I feel like I'd
trust my dad more than the--
- I trust your dad implicitly.
- Aw, you're so sweet.
- How does he feel
about the wall?
- Well he's out of that business
now, he's been out so long.
- What's he do?
- He does construction
over there and mechanic.
- What kind of construction?
- Probably like build house.
- House?
- Houses.
- What's a house made of?
- Different wood?
- The roof, and then the
- Wood.
- But then the roof, and then
- Wood, wood homes.
- Right, but as a
construction worker--
- Oh, you're tryna get
me there huh? (laughs)
- I'm not trying to
get you anywhere,
I'm just-- tell me what
a house is made of.
- Wood.
- And, what are the flat
parts on the side called?
- Wood.
- Wood...
- A wood house.
- Yeah but what's inside of a
house, what's a house made of?
- Wood floors.
- Wood floors and...
- Wood.
- What's on the side?
- I don't know, you tell me.
- What's that?
What's that?
Say the word wall motherfucker.
- Cement?
- Wall!
Your father builds the wall.
Well anyway, thank you
very much for being here.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I appreciate you.